[Music]
this is a song that was written to a
track that's a loop that was made with
the sounds that I made with my mouth
good morning John
if I had a dollar bill I would give a
piece to everyone there's a hole I wanna
fill that gets smaller every song that's
up cuz when I make me when I kiss a girl
well this might sound a bit surreal but
that's me given to the world don't wanna
buy the world a coke I do better telling
you to eat your Wheaties I wanna sing a
song I don't want to give you type-2
diabetes so when you party hard when you
go to the bank when you mow the yard or
you name your new son Hank while you're
moving it along this is the method that
drives the whole thing forward it's
possible I'm wrong but I think that
praise is absolutely unheard there's so
much that must be done so many folks to
do it and I know sometimes it's hard but
together we get through it no one does
it all alone nobody does it all alone
nobody does it all alone
nobody does it all alone if I had a
dollar bill I would give a piece to
everyone there's a hole I wanna fill but
back it's taller every song that's us
[Music]
thank you to the hundreds of people who
created beats using that sounds that I
made with my mouth that start at me you
can still go on beatbox with me it start
at me if you want to the link is in the
description there was like so much of
this going on in that video I just
wanted to do something different and
it's black and white because I didn't
want you to see the natural color of my
teeth honesty so John that song that I
just sang for you and everyone else is
about not being special and it's about
how not being special is not only like
really normal it's also really necessary
and really wonderful all the normal
things that we do every day taking care
of our kids and emptying out septic
tanks and learning things and having fun
and being silly
those are the things that make the world
work on the other hand Steve Jobs one of
the most special people of his
generation and one of my personal heroes
just died a couple of days ago and that
of course reminds us all how important
people like that always a little bit
dangerous to talk about someone right
after they've died because we can't do
like inflate their importance but it's
kind of difficult for me to imagine
inflating the importance of Steve Jobs
he made what we do possible John from
our first computer the Apple 2e that dad
got all the way to the computers that we
got in 2007 to get ready for this
project and all the software that we've
ever edited any video on that was all
because of Steve Jobs John we are in the
very not unique situation of having a
job that depended on Steve Jobs
existence I didn't know Steve Jobs I
don't know what kind of guy he was I
just know him through the things that he
created and because of the things that
he created he was important to me and he
made my life better and I think that the
world is less good without him and maybe
that's what we should be trying for in
the end for at the end of our lives for
the world to be less good without and if
that's the case maybe we don't have to
be special to be like Steve Jobs maybe
we just have to be good John I'll see
you on Monday